GIULIANI TOLD FOX NEWS A SHORT
TIME AGO, QUOTE THIS CASE IS
ESSENTIALLY OVER.
THEY ARE JUST IN DENIAL."
WHILE THE PRESIDENT APPEARS TO
BE CONSUMED ON AN ALMOST DAILY
BASIS WITH THE RUSSIA
INVESTIGATION, HE HAS MORE
PRESSING MATTERS AT HAND, SUCH
AS WHETHER HIS SUMMIT WITH
KIM JONG UN IS ON, OR OFF.
>> Reporter: MEETING WITH THE
PRESIDENT OF HIS PAKISTAN TODAY,
PRESIDENT TRUMP WAS UNCLEAR
ABOUT THE STATUS OF HIS SUMMIT
WITH KIM JONG UN.
>> President Trump: WE WILL
HAVE TO SEE.
>> Reporter: NORTH KOREA
PULLED OUT OF MEETINGS WITH
SOUTH KOREA, PROTESTING MILITARY
EXERCISES.
PYONGYANG ALSO LEFT OPEN TO
QUESTION WHETHER THE U.S. AND
NORTH KOREA MEETING WOULD BE
SCUTTLED.
WHITE HOUSE OFFICIALS THINK IT
ALL MIGHT BE SO MUCH
NORTH KOREAN BLUSTER.
>> THIS IS SOMETHING THAT WE
FULLY EXPECTED.
THE PRESIDENT IS VERY USED TWO
AND READY FOR TOUGH
NEGOTIATIONS, AND IF THEY WANT
TO MEET, WE WILL BE READY.
IF THEY DON'T, THAT'S OKAY,
ALSO.
WE WILL CONTINUE WITH A CAMPAIGN
OF MAXIMUM PRESSURE IF THAT'S
THE CASE, BUT IF THEY WANT TO
MEET THE PRESIDENT THEN WE WILL
CERTAINLY BE READY.
>> Reporter: WHILE MILITARY
EXERCISE WERE THE INITIAL
RATIONALE FOR ITS TANTRUM,
NORTH KOREA MADE CLEAR THAT ITS
ISSUE WITH JOHN BOLTON TOLD
FOX'S CHRIS BOLTON ON THE NINTH.
BOLTON SAYS THERE IS ALREADY A
MODEL FOR WHAT NORTH KOREAN
DENUCLEARIZATION WOULD LOOK
LIKE.
>> WE HAVE VERY MUCH IN MIND OF
THE LIBYA MODEL FROM 2003-2004.
THERE ARE OBVIOUSLY DIFFERENCES.
THE LIBYAN PROGRAM WAS MUCH
SMALLER BUT THAT WAS BASICALLY
THE AGREEMENT THAT WE MADE IT.
SO WE WILL WANT TO TEST
NORTH KOREA IN THIS FIRST
MEETING FOR EVIDENCE THAT THEY
HAVE MADE THAT STRATEGIC
DECISION.
>> Reporter: 'S SARAH HUCKABEE
SANDERS WALKED THAT BACK
INSISTING ANY DENUCLEARIZATION
WOULD COME FROM THE PRESIDENT,
AND THAT HE HAS HIS OWN IDEAS.
>> I HAVEN'T SEEN THAT THAT AS A
SPECIFIC THING.
I KNOW THAT COMMENT WAS MADE BUT
THERE IS NOT A COOKIE-CUTTER
MODEL ON HOW THIS WORKS.
THIS IS THE PRESIDENT TRUMP
MODEL, HE WILL RUN THIS THE WAY
HE SEES FIT AND WE ALL KNOW THAT
YOU ARE AWARE THAT HE IS THE
BEST NEGOTIATOR.
>> Reporter: WE ALSO GOT SENT
ME AN INSIGHT ON WHY RUDY
GIULIANI DROPPED A BOMBSHELL ON
THE SECOND THAT HE REIMBURSED
MICHAEL COHEN FOR THE PAYMENT TO
STORMY DANIELS.
AND IN A REPORT RELEASED BY THE
OFFICE OF ETHICS,
PRESIDENT TRUMP REPORTS THAT IN
2016, EXPENSES WERE RETURNED BY
ONE OF DONALD J. TRUMP'S
ATTORNEYS, MICHAEL COHEN.
MR. COHEN SOUGHT REIMBURSEMENT
OF THOSE EXPENSES AND HE WAS
REIMBURSED IN 2017.
THE PRESIDENT CONTENDS HE WAS
NOT REQUIRED TO REPORT THE
REIMBURSEMENT, BUT DID SO IN THE
INTEREST OF TRANSPARENCY.
OGE DISAGREED AND A COMMENT
SAYING, IT CONCLUDED THAT THE
INFORMATION RELATED TO THE
PAYMENT MADE BY MR. COHEN WAS
REQUIRED TO BE REPORTED.
OGE ADDED THAT THE PRESIDENT HAS
NOW MET THE REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS.
THE QUESTION, WHY DIDN'T THE
PRESIDENT BEFORE THE PAYMENT TO
STORMY DANIELS AND REIMBURSEMENT
TO COHEN LAST YEAR?
IN MARCH, CITIZENS FOR
RESPONSIBILITY AND ETHICS IN
WASHINGTON FILED SUIT FOR THE
DOA AND OGE WANTING TO KNOW IF
HIS FAILURE TO REPORT THE
JUNE 17 DISCLOSURE WAS KNOWING
AND WILLFUL.
>> THE ACTING DIRECTOR OF THE
OFFICE OF GOVERNMENT ETHICS SENT
THE REPORT AND ACCOMPANYING
LETTER TO ATTORNEY GENERAL ROD
ROSENSTEIN FOR FURTHER
INVESTIGATION, OR AT LEAST
FURTHER CONSIDERATION, AS TO WHY
GIULIANI MADE THAT STATEMENT TO
SEAN HANNITY BACK ON MAY 2ND.
SOURCES TELL FOX NEWS THAT HE
WAS AWARE THAT THE PAYMENTS
WOULD COME OUT OF THE
PRESIDENT'S FINANCIAL DISCLOSURE
AND WANTED TO GET AHEAD OF IT.
BY GETTING AHEAD OF IT, BRET, IT
WOULD BE GIULIANI THAT TOOK THE
HIT AND NOT THE PRESIDENT.
>> Bret: WE HAVE RUDY GIULIANI
ON THE LAURA INGRAHAM HAM SHOW
TONIGHT AT 10:00 P.M.
ROGER STONES SOCIAL MEDIA
DIRECTOR IN THE SHOW TODAY.
WHAT'S THAT ABOUT?
HE ISSUED A SUBPOENA TO JASON
SULLIVAN, HE WAS A GOOD FRIEND
OF THE PRESIDENT, ASSOCIATE OF
THE PRESIDENT IN 2016.
HIS SOCIAL MEDIA DIRECTOR.
WE CONTACTED SULLIVAN AND HE
CONFIRMED THAT HE DID INDEED
RECEIVE A SUBPOENA BUT WOULD GO
MUCH BEYOND THAT.
THIS IS AN INDICATION, BRET,
THAT MUELLER MAY BE LOOKING INTO
ANY EVIDENCE THAT ROGER STONE
KNEW WHAT WIKILEAKS WAS UP TO
WHEN IT WAS RELEASING ALL OF
THOSE CLINTON EMAILS THAT
EXTENSIVELY, AT LEAST ALLEGEDLY,
HAD BEEN HACKED BY RUSSIA.